One of the things I do to save money so I can stay home with my babies
is make my own laundry detergent.
Stay to the end to screenshot my recipe.
I start with arm and hammer baking soda,
which we buy in bulk. Washing soda,
which has been used in laundry for a century.
You do wanna be careful with this if you have cloth diapers,
but I strip mine at the end of every couple months.
But I promise you,
as the mom of two and a wife of a very dirty farmer husband,
it gets out all the stains you need it to.
This was a three dollar bag of Epsom salt from Amazon.
And yes, you can also add it into your bathtub.
Mixing it is very therapeutic.
Any type of natural sea salt,
and if you would like it scented,
my favorite is the Citrus Twist from doterra.
I'm sure Young Living has their same twist, huh?
Unintended on an oil that you can use.
I add 25 drops because I like it smelling good.
Well, my husband does.
Mix, mix,
because that's my favorite part.
Most importantly to note here,
these are natural oils
and it protects all the endocrine systems of my family,
which means I am protecting their future offspring.
Yes, guys,
I am talking about your swimmers.
It's very concentrated
and you only need a tablespoon to 2 tablespoons per load.
This is an easy way to save money.
Screenshot the recipe and double if you like.